(audience cheering)
- I was like, wear your black leather.
- Really? Yeah, we look good.
We're very, like New York.
- I, you know what,
I was actually, it's
a solid choice really.
I was like, I want to look
more New York and elevated.
Thank you for noticing.
- You're killing it, yeah.
- Have y'all met before?
- Well, backstage
Backstage, yeah.
- It was so awesome.
This is way back there, like 10 feet.
It's like this is the best
part of doing this show,
is that every time I'm on
I like get to meet someone.
I'm kind of fangirling over.
- [Kelly] That's me too.
- It's so cool.
And last time I think
it was, it was Dr. Phil,
like we became friends after sitting
on the couch and he
invited me on his podcast.
So I'm excited to do your podcast.
(laughing)
- I wanna start one just
so you could be on it.
- [Kelly] So thank you for the invite.
- (laughing) premiere episode.
It's awesome.
And you sounded so good.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're very nice.
Wait, well, speaking of music
this is insane and I love you for this.
I heard that you spent 25
grand on Taylor Swift tickets.
- Oh, okay.
Yes, I did.
I just wanna say that it
was a conscious decision
because I, I,
(Kelly laughing)
- So that makes it better
okay, I, well, okay.
I went to, I've been to nine
eras tour shows this year.
Like when I'm not on tour,
I just like go to her tour.
It just like fills my
life up with so much joy.
I'm in my late thirties,
- That's beautiful
- I'm in my latest thirties.
And I just feel like I don't have kids.
(crowd laughing)
And I kind of did the math and I'm like,
if I had kids I'd be paying for like
dance camp and swim lessons.
- [Kelly] Kids are expensive.
- I should just use all this money.
And I was gonna freeze my eggs in January
and that's like about how much it costs.
And then I just decided not to freeze 'em.
I decided to burn them.
(laughing)
And so it's, it's a new
thing they're offering.
- So you saved a lot of money.
- Yeah. So exactly.
You know what, I'm gonna take that chunk
of money that I was gonna use to do that
and I'm just gonna like
have a really fun summer.
So I went buck wild.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, and it was so fun.
I I, yeah, that's me just
gazing at her, disturbing her.
I mean, and I like-
- [Kelly] Disturbing her.
- I feel like it's distracting.
I don't know.
I wanna ask you guys, like
when you're performing
and there's someone in the front row
because at comedy shows,
people just sit down
no one's like screaming
my, you know, name and like
so I don't know what the perspective is.
So I'm front row and
I'm taking video of her.
I have her phone case 'cause
I buy everything she owns.
There's like a, an account
I follow that tells you
tells you what clothes she has.
- Her security somewhere
right now is like Nikki.
- It's all the stuff she owns
under a certain price point I buy.
But I have her phone case
and I remember at one
point I was filming her
and I could see her
kind of look and go like
is that my phone?
Like, you know when you
see your own phone case?
my phone, is it like,
do you blur your eyes?
Like is it distracting
when people are singing
and like maybe they're
singing the wrong lyric?
Does it ever like mess you up?
- Well usually I'm the one
singing the wrong lyrics.
(laughing)
- Yeah. Does it distract you?
- No. I mean, you know,
there's always somebody crazy
in the front.
If, I like that person.
You, you make me happy.
Okay look crazy girl.
- I've been told I'm not
the most enthusiastic,
like person in the front row.
- But y'all get hecklers.
I feel like we don't get
hecklers in that sense.
- [Nikki] That's true.
- So comedy gets hecklers.
- Yeah.
- So wait season three of
F Boy, what's going on?
Other than, F.
- F Boy Island is an
insane show that I host.
It's a reality dating show.
That is,
You know, a bunch of guys that show up
there are three girls looking for love
and then there's a bunch of guys
and half of them are there for the money
and to lie to girls.
- [Kelly] Can we just stop for a minute?
- It's ridiculous.
- It's awesome.
- Thank you for saying
that because it's true.
No one's really looking
for love on reality TV.
- It's amazing.
It's a crazy place-
- It happens sometimes.
- It does happen.
I always say like, no, what?
This is a terrible place to
go to actually find love.
Because it's a reality show.
But people do really fall in love.
I mean it is a thing
that I've watched happen
with my own eyes.
But the the cool thing
about this show is that
you know, every time you
watch a reality dating show,
you kind of go,
that guy's not here for the right reasons.
Like, don't pick him girl.
But on our show, these guys have admitted
that they're not here
for the right reasons.
So there'll be a clip of them being like,
I have to go on this date today
and I don't even like her.
I'm going to pretend the whole time
I'm just here for the money.
And some of these guys,
the good news is that some of these guys
that came there for the money, they
the reason that they are scoundrel guys is
because they're able to be,
they can be on their phones all the time.
They can go swimming,
they don't have to like
stay in a relationship.
But on this island we force them
to like go on dates multiple times.
So they, for the first time in their lives
they have intimacy and they start to like,
like these women and kind of go,
what have I've been doing my whole life?
Like I have feelings for the first time
and they kind of like
ditch their F boy ways.
And it's so, we have both
of it where they're like
they're truly the worst
people in the world.
- Yeah
And then we have some guys
that kind of change their ways.
It is-
- That's interesting for me,
you start with these people you walk in,
and then all of a sudden
you leave this season
and it's like how different
people have changed or
or you were like, no, that one was a tool.
- [Nikki] Oh, totally
Yes, exactly. And, but
it's fun to play along
and guess like who is who.
It's just a great show and
yeah, it's a comedy show too.
- I love that.
- It's so fun.
- So fun.
Alright, we need a
commercial break everybody.
F Boy Island airs Mondays on The CW.
We're gonna be right back.